peut-être élargir votre perspective
sur la vision du monde de Steve Bannon.
Parce qu'il est parfois critiqué en termes très simples
comme une personne dangereuse, raciste, xénophobe, suscitant la colère.
Mais ce n'est pas tout ; c'est peut-être une simplification injuste.
DB : Je pense que c'est vrai en partie,
mais une autre partie est vraie aussi.
Il fait partie d'un mouvement mondial.
C'est comme être près des marxistes en 1917.
Il y a lui, il y a le parti UKIP, le Front national en France,
Il y a Poutine, il y a une version Turque, une version Philippine.
Nous devons reconnaître que c'est un mouvement intellectuel global,
qui croit que la sagesse et la vertu
ne résident pas dans la conversation et la civilité
comme beaucoup d'entre nous du côté de l'illumination du monde.
Elles résident chez le peuple, "volk" en allemand,
dans la sagesse commune et instinctive des gens ordinaires.
Et la vertu essentielle de ces gens est d'être toujours menacé par des étrangers.
Et il a une stratégie pour savoir comment y arriver.
Il a une série de politiques pour soulever les gens
et répudier les étrangers,
que ces étrangers soient l'Islam, les Mexicains, les médias,
les élites côtières ...
Il y a toute une vision du monde, elle est très cohérente.
J'en ai un peu plus de respect pour lui.
Je déteste ce qu'il représente et je pense qu'il a tort sur le fond,
mais c'est intéressant de voir quelqu'un avec des idées
trouver un vecteur, Donald Trump,
et ensuite essayer de prendre le contrôle de la Maison Blanche
afin de faire avancer son point de vue.
CA : Donc, c'est presque devenu la question centrale de notre époque :
pouvez-vous être patriote mais avoir aussi une mentalité mondiale ?
Ces deux choses implacablement opposées l'une à l'autre ?
Je veux dire, beaucoup de conservateurs
et dans la mesure où c'est une catégorie différente,
de nombreux partisans de Trump,
sont furieux contre les élites côtières et les mondialistes
parce qu'ils les voient comme n'applaudissant pas l'Amérique,
n'embrassant pas entièrement les valeurs américaines.
Avez-vous vu ça dans vos conversations avec les gens,
dans votre compréhension de leur mentalité ?
GC : Je pense qu'il y a une énorme différence entre -
je déteste classer les gens en catégories,
mais les Américains du centre contre les gens qui vivent sur les côtes.
C'est une existence tout à fait différente.
J'ai grandi au Minnesota, je comprends l'Amérique du centre,
et je ne l'ai jamais oublié.
Peut-être est-ce pour ça que je comprends ce qu'il s'est passé ici,
parce que ces gens ont souvent l'impression que personne ne les écoute,
et que nous ne nous concentrons que sur la Californie et New York.
Et je pense que c'était une énorme raison pour laquelle Trump a été élu.
Ces personnes avaient l'impression qu'on les entendaient.
Que ce soit du patriotisme ou pas,
je ne suis pas certaine.
Je sais une chose :
plein de choses dont Trump a parlé hier soir ne sont pas conservatrices.
Si Hillary Clinton avait fait ce discours,
aucun Répulicain ne se serait levé pour applaudir.
Il parle de dépenser un trillion de dollars en infrastructures.
Ce n'est pas une vision conservatrice.
Il a parlé du mandat du gouvernement pour le congé maternité.
Beaucoup de femmes peuvent aimer ça,
ce n'est pas une vision conservatrice, c'est donc fascinant
que les gens qui ont aimé ce qu'était son message pendant la campagne,
comment pensez-vous qu'ils réagiront à ça ?
DB : j'ai grandi à Lower Manhattan,
dans le triangle entre ABC Carpets, la librairie Strand
et le restaurant Odeon
(Rires)
GC : Venez nous voir au Minnesota !
CA : Vous êtes membre de l'élite côtière, mon vieux.
Mais qu'avez-vous pensé du discours hier soir ?
Cela semblait être un mouvement vers une position plus modérée,
en apparence.
DB : C'était son meilleur discours,
et ça l'a rendu moins bizarre.
Je pense qu'il est un fou de morale,
et je pense que ça le détruira,
le fait qu'il ne sait tout simplement rien de rien
et n'est curieux de rien.
(Rires)
Mais si vous enlevez ces faiblesses mineures,
on l'a vu sous son meilleur jour,
et c'était révélateur pour moi de le voir ainsi,
parce qu'il a exposé une contradiction cruciale qu'il doit affronter,
que beaucoup de ce qu'il fait offre de la sécurité.
« J'ordonne des frontières fermées,
je vais sécuriser le monde pour vous, pour mon peuple. »
Si vous regardez réellement ses politiques économiques,
la réforme des soins de santé, les comptes privés de soins de santé,
ce n'est pas la sécurité, c'est le risque.
Les bons scolaires : c'est le risque, la déréglementation : c'est un risque.
Il y a vraiment une contradiction entre la sécurité de l'état d'esprit
et les politiques, qui sont très axées sur le risque.
Ce que je dirais, en particulier ayant passé cette année,
les gens du Minnesota rural, au Nouveau-Mexique -
ils ont assez de risques dans leur vie.
Et ils vont donc dire, « Non, merci. »
L'abrogation des soins de santé échouera pour cette raison.
CA : Mais malgré les critiques que vous venez de faire de lui,
il semble au moins qu'il écoute
un large éventail de voix ;
ce n'est pas comme si tout le monde venait du même endroit.
Peut-être cela conduit-il à un certain chaos et une certaine confusion, mais …
GC : Je ne pense pas qu'il écoute un large éventail de voix.
Il écoute très peu de gens.
C'est juste l'impression que j'en ai.
Je crois que certaines des choses qu'il a dit hier soir
étaient visiblement d'Ivanka.
Je crois donc qu'il l'écoutait avant de faire ce discours.
Il était Trump le Teleprompter hier soir, par opposition à Trump le Twitter.
Et c'est pourquoi, avant de venir ici,
j'ai dit « on ferait mieux de vérifier Twitter
pour voir si quelque chose a changé. »
Je pense qu'il faut garder à l'esprit
que c'est un personnage unique,
quel était le niveau qu'on attendait hier soir ?
Était-ce ici ou ici ou là ?
Donc il arrive et fait un discours politique qui a de l'allure,
et tout le monde dit, « Hé, il peut le faire. »
Ça dépend dans quelle direction il va.
DB : Nous essayons de construire des ponts ici,
et surtout pour un public qui peut être méprisant pour Trump,
il est important de dire, non, c'est réel.
Mais comme j'essaye vraiment de tenir une heure en lui montrant du respect,
ma thyroïde augmente,
parce que je pense que les bizarreries de son caractère
sont réellement condamnables et vont le condamner.
CA : Vous avez la réputation d'un conservateur.
Les gens vous décrivent comme centre droit,
et pourtant ici vous avez cette réaction viscérale contre lui
et une partie de ce qu'il défend.
Je veux dire, je suis… comment avez-vous une conversation ?
Les gens qui le soutiennent, à l'évidence jusqu'à présent,
sont probablement assez exaltés.
Il a certainement montré un réel engagement
dans beaucoup de ce qu'il a promis de faire,
et il y a un fort désir de changer radicalement le système.
Les gens détestent ce que le gouvernement est devenu et ce qu'il a fait d'eux.
GC : Je suis complètement d'accord.
je pense que hier, quand il proposait un programme gouvernemental énorme
qu'on appelait avait un "stimulus", je trouve cela ironique.
Dépenser un trillion de dollars,
ce n'est pas conservateur.
Je ne crois pas vraiment qu'il soit républicain.
DB : En tant que quelqu'un qui s'identifie comme conservateur,
je voudrais dire d'abord,
être conservateur c'est croire dans les limites de la politique.
Samuel Johnson a dit : « de tout ce que les cœurs humains endurent,
les rois peuvent en causer et en guérir si peu. »
La politique est un domaine limité ;
ce qui compte le plus est la nature morale de la société.
Je dois penser que le caractère est primordial,
et un homme qui ne passe pas le seuil de caractère
ne peut pas être un bon président.
Deuxièmement, je suis le genre de conservateur qui,
je reviens à Alexander Hamilton,
qui était une star latine du hip-hop
(Rires)
mais sa définition de l'Amérique était très orientée vers l'avenir.
C'était un garçon pauvre des îles
qui a connu une ascension rapide et incroyable vers le succès,
il voulait que le gouvernement donne aux enfants pauvres
une chance de réussir, avec un gouvernement limité
mais dynamique pour créer une mobilité sociale.
Pour lui, pour Lincoln et pour Teddy Roosevelt,
l'idée de l'Amérique était l'idée de l'avenir.
Nous avons eu la division, le racisme et l'esclavage.
Mais nous avons un avenir commun.
La définition de l'Amérique que Steve Bannon représente est rétrograde.
elle est nostalgique, passéiste.
Et ce n'est pas l'identité américaine.
C'est traditionnellement l'identité russe.
C'est leur définition de la vertu
C'est une trahison fondamentale
de ce qu'établissait le conservatisme.
CA : Je voudrais vous entendre dire,
- si nous voyons des commentaires venir -
Oh, bien, en voilà un.
JAC : J'ai essayé de convaincre des amis progressistes
qu'ils doivent comprendre ce qui motive les partisans de Trump,
mais beaucoup ont cessé d'essayer de comprendre,
face à ce qu'ils perçoivent comme des mensonges, de l'égoïsme et de la haine
Comment tendre la main à ces gens, le Tea Party à gauche,
pour essayer de combler cette fracture ?
GC: Je pense en fait qu'il y a des points communs dans la colère
comme je l'ai déjà exprimé.
Vous pouvez venir à la table, les deux étant passionnés par quelque chose.
Au moins, vous vous sentez concernés.
Et j'aimerais croire au compromis,
même si c'est devenu un mot horrible.
Vous avez l'extrême gauche et l'extrême droite,
et un compromis... jamais.
Ces groupes ne veulent même pas y penser.
Mais vous avez tout un tas d'électeurs, moi y compris,
qui sont des électeurs indépendants,
comme 40 % d'entre nous, n'est-ce pas ?
Il y a donc une énorme faction d'Amérique qui veut voir le changement
et veut voir les gens se réunir.
c'est juste que nous devons comprendre
comment le faire.
CA : Parlons-en une minute,
parce que nous avons ces Dialogues TED, nous essayons de combler.
Il y a beaucoup de gens là-bas, en ce moment, peut-être surtout à gauche,
qui pensent que c'est terrible,
en fait, la seule réponse morale à la grande tyrannie
qui pourrait être sur le point d'émerger en Amérique
est de résister à chaque étape, est de se battre jusqu'au bout,
c'est une erreur d'essayer de le faire.
Luttez !
Y a-t-il un cas pour cela ?
DB : Il faut définir "lutter".
Si ça signifie se battre au sens littéral, alors non.
Si ça signifie protester, peut-être pour sensibiliser
ça semble bien.
Mais si vous voulez le changement, c'est par les partis et la politique.
On organise des partis,
qui sont des coalitions grandes, diverses, et désordonnés
et on s'engage en politique,
la politique est toujours moralement insuffisante
parce que c'est toujours un ensemble de compromis.
mais la politique est une rivalité entre des vérités partielles ...
les Trump ont une partie de la vérité en Amérique.
Trump lui-même est la mauvaise réponse à la bonne question,
mais ils ont une certaine vérité,
qu'on trouve dans l'épidémie des opiacés à travers le pays,
dans la propagation de la solitude,
c'est la vérité chez les gens dont les vies sont inversées.
Ils ont atteint le succès professionnel à 30 ans,
et n'ont fait que descendre depuis.
Et donc, le comprendre ne nécessite pas de se battre.
Il faut discuter et puis demander,
« Par quoi nous allons remplacer Trump ? »
GC : Il y avait des combats hier soir, même au moment du discours,
on a vu venir les femmes démocrates vêtues de blanc
pour honorer le mouvement des Suffragettes.
Je me souviens bien pendant la campagne.
certains partisans de Trump voulaient se débarrasser de l'amendement
qui a permis aux femmes de voter.
J'ai pensé : quoi ?
Je ne sais pas si c'est la bonne façon de lutter.
C'était intéressant, parce que je cherchais dans le public
les femmes qui ne portait pas de blanc.
Il se passe beaucoup de choses
et il y a beaucoup de façons de lutter sans forcément faire ça.
CA : Une question clé, pour moi :
les gens qui ont voté pour Trump mais sont plutôt au centre,
ils sont peut-être susceptible d'être persuadés,
sont-ils plus susceptibles d'être persuadés par un soulèvement passionné
de gens qui disent : « Non, non, non, vous ne pouvez pas faire ça ! »
ou est-ce que ça va les gonfler et les repousser ?
DB : Comment sommes-nous persuadés?
Est-il persuasif d'entendre : « Vous êtes un bigot,
vous soutenez le fanatisme, vous soutenez le sexisme.
Vous êtes une ascension primitive et fasciste d'un passé autoritaire . » ?
Ce ne sera probablement pas trop convaincant pour vous.
La façon de persuader chacun d'entre nous est :
a) afficher un respect élémentaire pour le point de vue et dire :
« Je pense que ce type ne va pas vous amener où vous devez aller ».
Et il y a deux phrases que vous avez entendu maintes et maintes fois,
partout dans le pays.
Un, l'expression "Amérique rurale".
on entend ça depuis des années
mais je dirais que cette année, je l'ai entendue presque chaque heure,
un sentiment d'invisibilité.
Et puis le sens donné à l'expression "politiquement correct".
Cette rébellion : « On ne nous permet même pas de dire ce qu'on pense. »
J'enseigne à Yale.
Le rétrécissement du débat est réel
CA : C'est un piège dans lequel les libéraux sont tombés
en célébrant des causes en lesquelles ils croient vraiment,
souvent exprimées de manière politiquement correcte.
Ils ont fait des dégâts, ils ont dégouté les gens.
DB : Je dirais que cependant, beaucoup d'arguments,
avec "la descente vers le fascisme" "l'autoritarisme" -
les gens trouvent ça exagéré.
J'ai écrit huit millions de chroniques anti-Trump,
mais c'est un problème, surtout pour les médias côtiers,
qu'à chaque fois qu'il fait quelque chose un peu mal,
on le dit à l'antenne à 11 heures, tous les jours
et ça fragilise notre crédibilité à un moment donné.
CA : Crier au loup un peu trop fort et un peu trop tôt.
Mais le moment viendra peut-être où il faudra crier au loup.
GC : Une des choses les plus importantes pour moi
est comment les médias conservateurs gère Trump.
Vont-ils l'interpeller quand les choses ne sont pas vraies,
ou bien vont-ils l'accompagner ?
Pour moi, c'est ce qui est essentiel dans toute cette discussion,
parce que lorsque vous avez des partisans de quelqu'un
qui ne se soucient pas vraiment s'il dit la vérité ou non,
ça peut être très dangereux.
Pour moi, c'est le problème : comment les médias conservateurs vont-ils réagir ?
Vous les avez interpelés.
Mais comment les autres formes de médias conservateurs traitent de cela
alors que nous avançons ?
DB : Tout est décalé.
Les médias conservateurs étaient Fox, Charles Krauthammer ou George Will.
Il ne sont plus les médias conservateurs.
Il y a un tas d'autres institutions plus à droite,
Breitbart et Infowars, Alex Jones, Laura Ingraham,
et ce sont eux qui sont maintenant sa base, Fox pas tellement.
CA : Ma dernière question pour le moment est juste sur la question de la vérité.
c'est ce qui fait le plus peur aux gens maintenant,
qu'il n'y a pas d'accord, à l'échelle nationale, sur ce qui est vrai.
Je n'ai jamais rien vu de pareil,
quand les faits sont tellement contestés.
Tout votre journal, monsieur, livre de fausses nouvelles tous les jours.
DB : Et échoue.
(Rires)
CA: Et échoue. Je vous plains.
Mais y a-t-il un chemin
par lequel on pourrait commence à obtenir une sorte de consensus
pour croire les mêmes choses ?
Les communautés en ligne peuvent-elles jouer un rôle ici ?
Comment réparer ça ?
GC : Je comprendsce qu'il s'est passé.
C'est une autre vague d'émotion qui submergeait l'Amérique rurale
et n'a pas été entendue,
le fait de penser que les grands médias étaient de parti pris.
Il y a une différence cependant, entre être de parti pris et être faux.
Pour moi, c'est une distinction très importante dans cette conversation.
Disons simplement qu'il y avait un parti pris dans les grands médias.
D'accord. Il y a donc des moyens d'essayer de réparer ça.
Mais ce que Trump fait est en train de les neutraliser et de dire :
« Ecoutez, nous allons dire que tout ça est faux. »,
C'est là que ça devient dangereux.
CA : Pensez-vous qu'assez de ses partisans
tiennent plus à la vérité qu' à...
de même, le principe de ne pas soutenir quelque chose
qui n'est manifestement pas vrai compte vraiment,
alors y aura-t-il une correction à un moment donné ?
DB ; Je pense la vérité finit par sortir.
Par exemple, Trump a fondé une grande part de sa politique économique
sur l'idée que les Américains ont perdu des emplois dans l'industrie
parce qu'ils ont été volés par les Chinois.
C'est peut-être 13% des emplois qui sont partis.
La vérité est que 87% des emplois ont été remplacés par la technologie.
C'est simplement la vérité.
Et, par conséquent, quand il dit,
« Je vais mettre un terme au Partenariat Trans-Pacifique
et tous les emplois vont revenir. », ils ne reviendront pas.
Donc, c'est un fait réel, selon ma conviction.
Et....
(Rires)
GC : Ses partisans pensent que c'est la vérité,
peu importe combien de fois vous le dites,
ils le croient toujours.
DB : Mais finalement, soit des emplois reviendront ou ne reviendront pas,
et à ce moment-là, quelque chose fonctionnera ou non,
ça fonctionne ou pas non past à cause d'un excellent marketing,
mais ça marche car ça répond à un vrai problème
et je pense donc quela vérité sortira.
CA : Si vous avez une question, veuillez lever la main ici.
Yael Eisenstat : Je vais rester sur le sujet.
Je m'appelle Yael Eisenstat.
J'entends bien dans ce discours
comment nous devons tous parler plus entre nous
et mieux nous comprendre,
et j'ai même écrit et publié là dessus,
maintenant je continue à entendre les libéraux - oui, j'habite à New York,
on peut considérer que je suis libéral -
nous nous auto-analysons :
comment n'a-t-on pas compris aux États industriels ?
Que peut-on faire pour mieux comprendre l'Amérique rurale ?
et ce que j'aimerais savoir :
avez-vous vu des tentatives ou des conversations de l'Amérique rurale
pour mieux comprendre les élites côtières ?
Parce que je me sens autant insultée d'être identifiée comme élite côtière
que quelqu'un d'Amérique rurale dont on dit qu'on ne s'y arrête jamais
et qu'on n'écoute pas.
CA : J'entend Facebook vous applaudir...
(Rires)
DB : Je dirais - et j'ai été conservateur toute ma vie d'adulte -
lorsque vous grandissez conservateur,
vous apprenez à parler les deux langues.
Parce que si je vais écouter de la musique,
je ne vais pas écouter Ted Nugent.
Donc beaucoup de mes groupes de rock préférés sont tous de gauche.
Si je vais aller dans une école,
j'irai probablement à l'école où la culture est libérale.
Si je vais regarder une sitcom,
une émission de fin de soirée, elle sera libérale.
Si je vais lire un bon journal, ce sera le New York Times.
Alors, on apprend à parler les deux langues.
Et, en fait, au moins depuis plusieurs années,
quand j'ai commencé à National Review avec William F. Buckley,
ça nous a rendu plus pointus,
parce qu'on se disputait avec les gens tous les jours.
Le problème maintenant c'est qu' on a une ghettoïsation à droite
on peut vivre entièrement dans le monde de droite,
donc, la qualité de l'argument à droite a diminué,
parce que vous n'êtes pas dans l'autre camp tout le temps.
Mais je pense que si vous vivez au Minnesota, dans l'Iowa ou en Arizona,
les élites côtières vous font savoir qu'elles sont là,
donc on connait cette langue aussi,
mais ce n'est pas l'inverse.
CA : Mais qu'est-ce que l'Amérique rurale ne pas comprend pas aux élites côtières ?
La critique est,
vous n'avez pas de vrais problèmes.
Il y a un sentiment de snobisme, un élitisme très désagréable.
Qu'est-ce qu'ils ne comprennent pas ?
Si vous pouviez planter une partie de la vérité
de la mentalité de quelqu'un dans cette salle, par exemple,
que leur diriez-vous ?
DB : À quel point nous sommes merveilleux.
(Rires)
Non, je rejette la catégorie.
Le problème du populisme est le même problème qu'avec l'élitisme.
C'est juste un préjugé
fondé sur une généralisation excessive de la distinction de classe sociale
qui est trop simpliste pour être appliquée à la réalité.
Les New Yorkais parmi nous savent qu'il y a des gens à New York
qui sont absolument géniaux et d'autres qui sont pathétiques,
si vous vivez dans l'Iowa, il y a des gens géniaux et d'autres pathétiques.
Ça ne dépend pas de vos diplômes,
ou d'où vous vivez dans le pays.
La distinction est un simplification grossière
pour susciter le pouvoir politique.
GC : Mais j'encourage les gens à regarder les informations à la télé
ou lire une chronique qu'ils qude d'habitude ils ignoreraient.
Donc, si vous êtes un partisan de Trump, regardez l'autre côté pendant un jour
parce que vous devez sortir de la bulle
si vous voulez avoir une conversation un jour.
Et les deux côtés - alors, si vous êtes libéral,
alors regardez quelque chose de très conservateur.
Lisez une chronique que vous ne lisez pas normalement,
parce que vous aurez une perspective de ce que pense l'autre côté,
et, à mon avis, c'est un début pour se rejoindre.
Je m'inquiète de la même chose que vous, de ces bulles.
Si vous regardez certaines entités,
vous n'avez aucune idée de ce dont le reste du monde parle.
DB : Je pense non seulement il faut regarder,
mais faire partie d'une groupe qui se réunit au moins une fois par mois,
qui vous met en contact avec des gens différents de vous,
est une chose que nous devons tous faire.
Je pourrais me tromper
mais je pense aux voitures les plus vendues dans ce pays.
Je pense que les trois ou quatre premières sont tous des pickups.
Alors demandez-vous : qui je connais qui possèdent un pickup ?
Ce pourrait être très peu de gens voire personne l pour beaucoup de gens.
C'est un genre de signal d'alerte.
Où puis-je m'inscrire à un club
où j'aurais des points communs avec celui qui conduit un pickup
car nous avons un intérêt commun ?
CA : Internet y contribue parfaitement.
Une question ici de Chris Ajemian :
« Selon vous, comment la structure de la communication
en particulier la prévalence des médias sociaux et des contenus personnalisés
peut être utilisée pour rassembler une fracture politique,
au lieu de classer des communautés dans les chambres d'écho ? »
Il semble que Facebook et Google, depuis l'élection,
travaillent avec acharnement là-dessus,
ils essaient de modifier les algorithmes
afin qu'ils n'amplifient pas les fausses nouvelles
dans la mesure où c'est arrivé la dernière fois.
Voyez-vous d'autres signes positifs de… ?
GC : ... ou amplifier un côté de l'équation.
CA : Exactement.
GC : Je pense que c'était l'argument constant de la droite,
que les médias sociaux et internet en général
mettaient des articles vers le haut qui n'était pas leur vision du monde.
Je pense, encore une fois, que ça alimente la colère :
« Vous avancez quelque chose et ce n'est pas ce que je crois. »
Mais les médias sociaux ont tout changé,
et je pense que Trump est l'exemple de Twitter qui change absolument tout.
Et de son point de vue,
il va vers le peuple américain sans filtre,
CA : Question du public.
Destiny : Salut, Je m'appelle Destiny
J'ai une question concernant
le politiquement correct et je suis curieuse :
depuis quand est-il devenu synonyme de faire taire,
plutôt qu'une façon de parler des autres
pour leur montrer du respect et préserver leur dignité ?
GC : Je pense que les médias conservateurs ont matraqué ce problème
depuis 10 ans.
Je pense qu'ils ont vraiment passé beaucoup de temps
à parler du politiquement correct,
et de comment les gens devraient avoir la capacité de dire ce qu'ils pensent.
Une autre raison pour laquelle Trump est devenu populaire :
parce qu'il dit ce qu'il pense.
Ça me fait aussi penser au fait
que je crois qu'il y a beaucoup de personnes en Amérique
qui sont d'accord avec Steve Bannon,
mais ils ne le diraient jamais publiquement,
et donc voter pour Trump leur a donné l'opportunité
d'être d'accord avec lui en silence.
DB : Sur la question de l'immigration, c'est un point de vue légitime
que nous avons trop d'immigrants dans le pays,
que c'est trop coûteux économiquement.
CA : Que nous avons trop…
DB : les immigrants dans le pays, surtout venus d'Angleterre.
(Rires)
GC : J'aime l'accent britannique, ok ?
CA : Pardon, Amérique, je suis désolé.
(Rires)
Je m'en vais.
DB : Mais il est devenu presque inadmissible de le dire,
parce que c'était un signe que vous devez être un fanatique.
Donc, le politiquement correct ne s'attaquait pas qu'au discours
que nous trouverions tous absolument choquant,
il s'attaquait au discours qui était légitime,
et alors il transformait le discours et la pensée en action,
la traitant comme un crime,
et les gens sont licenciés et les gens expulsés des écoles,
on écrivait des codes de discours.
Maintenant, il y a des équipes de diversité,
si vous dites quelque chose qui offense quelqu'un,
comme "Fumer est dangereux" on peut dire "Vous insultez mon groupe"
et l'équipe de l'administration descendra dans votre dortoir
et lancera la police de la pensée sur vous.
Il y a donc eu un véritable rétrécissement de ce qui est permis de dire.
Et c'est partiellement légitime.
Certains mots devraient être sanctionnés socialement,
mais ça a servi à faire respecter un programme politique.
CA : C'est un projet
que vous encourageriez les libéraux à avoir, - les progressistes -
pour repenser les règles de base du politiquement correct
et accepter un langage un peu plus gênant
dans certaines circonstances ?
Pensez-vous que ce sera résolu
dans une mesure où d'autres ne seront pas aussi offensés ?
DB : La plupart des universités américaines,
en particulier les universités d'élite, sont massivement à gauche,
c'est une tentation facile
d'utiliser votre pouvoir culturel écrasant pour essayer d'imposer une sorte de pensée
que vous pensez être bonne et correcte.
Donc, doutez donc un peu plus, demandez vous, « on fait ça ? ».
Deuxièmement, mon université, l'Université de Chicago,
a envoyé une lettre qui a dit, plus d'espaces sécurisés.
Il n'y aura pas de critique de micro-agression.
Si on vous blesse moralement, bienvenue dans le monde de l'éducation.
Je pense que cette politique -
qui est adoptée par beaucoup de gens à gauche, d'ailleurs -
sert de correctif à ce qu'il s'est passé.
CA : Voici une question de Karen Holloway :
comment cultivons-nous une culture américaine
qui est à l'avant-garde, comme Hamilton,
qui s'attend à des changements et les traite,
plutôt que de vouloir que tout revienne à un passé fictif ?
C'est une question facile, non ?
GC : Eh bien, je crois encore dans le rêve américain,
et je pense ce que nous pouvons enseigner nos enfants sont les bases,
c'est-à-dire travailler dur
et croire en vous-même.
En Amérique, on peut réaliser tout ce qu'on veut.
On m'a dit ça chaque jour.
Quand je suis entrée dans le monde du travail,
j'ai découvert que ce n'est peut-être pas toujours vrai.
Mais j'y crois toujours.
Je suis peut-être trop optimiste.
Je regarde toujours vers l'avenir pour que ça continue.
DB : Je pense que vous êtes trop optimiste.
GC : C'est vrai ?
DB : Les chances qu'un jeune américain dépasse le salaire de ses parents,
il y a une génération, 86% l'ont fait.
Maintenant, 51% le font.
Il y a eu un problème dans la mobilité sociale dans le pays.
CA : Vous avez écrit que le siècle entier a été en gros une catastrophe,
que l'âge de l'évolution radieuse est terminé et que nous sommes en difficulté.
DB : Nous avons en moyenne, ajusté en fonction de la population,
une croissance de 2-3% pendant 50 ans,
maintenant nous avons eu moins d'1% de croissance.
Et il y a donc quelque chose qui transpire.
Et si je vais dire aux gens qu'ils devraient prendre des risques,
nous voyons une baisse rapide de la mobilité,
Le nombre de personnes qui déménagent d'un état à un autre,
et c'est particulièrement vrai chez les millénaires.
Les jeunes se déplacent moins.
Comment donner aux gens la sécurité qui leur fera prendre le risque ?
Je crois à la théorie d'attachement de l'éducation des enfants,
et la théorie de l'attachement est basé sur le slogan
que toute la vie est une série d'aventures audacieuses à partir d'une base sécurisée.
Vos parents vous ont-ils donné une base sécurisée ?
En tant que société, on n'a pas de base sécurisée,
et nous n'arriverons pas à cette prise de risque, cette éthique énergétique
à la Hamilton tant qu'on ne pourra pas fournir une base sécurisée.
CA : Je me demande si il y a matière
à créer un programme partagé, une conversation qui rapproche,
reconnaissant d'une part qu'il y a ce problème vraiment profond
que le système économique que nous avons construit
semble faillir en ce moment.
Deuxièmement, si vous avez raison et qu'il n'y a pas que les immigrants,
c'est probablement plus la faute de la technologie,
si vous pouviez gagner cet argument,
ça atténue ce qui me semble être le terrain qui divise le plus
entre les partisans de Trump et les autres, qui porte sur le rôle de l'autre.
C'est très offensant pour les gens à gauche de voir l'autre diabolisé
dans la mesure où l'autre semble être diabolisé.
C'est profondément immoral,
peut-être que les gens à gauche pourrait convenir, comme vous le dites,
que l'immigration s'est peut-être fait trop vite,
il existe une limite au-delà de laquelle les sociétés humaines luttent,
mais néanmoins tout ce problème est minimisé
si l'automatisation est la question-clé,
puis on essaye de travailler ensemble en admettant que c'est réel,
en reconnaissant que le problème n'a pas été abordé correctement
ni vu ou entendu,
et on essaye de comprendre comment reconstruire les communautés
en se servant de quoi ?
Cela me semble devenir la conversation fertile du futur :
comment reconstituons-nous les communautés dans cet âge moderne,
avec la technologie faisant ce qu'elle fait
réimaginons-nous ce brillant avenir ?
GC : C'est pourquoi je reviens à l'optimisme.
Je ne suis pas ... ce n'est pas comme si je ne regardais pas les faits,
où nous en sommes arrivés ou d'où nous sommes partis.
Mais bon sang, si nous ne regardons pas l'avenir d'un point de vue optimiste -
je m'y refuse pour l'instant.
Je n'élève pas mes enfants de 12 et 13 ans à dire : « Regarde, le monde est sombre. ».
CA : Nous allons avoir une autre question de la salle.
Homme : Salut. Bonjour. Pardon.
Vous avez tous deux mentionné le plan d'infrastructure et la Russie
et d'autres choses qui ne seraient pas
des priorités républicaines traditionnelles.
Que pensez-vous qui motivera les Républicains
à prendre position contre le Trumpisme ou quand cela arrivera-t-il ?
GC : Après hier soir, pas pendant un moment.
Il a beaucoup changé hier soir, je crois.
DB : Sa popularité chez les républicains : il a obtenu une approbation de 85%
plus que Reagan n'avait eu à son époque,
et c'est parce que la société vient d'être plus polarisée.
Les gens suivent le parti plus qu'avant.
Donc, si vous attendez que Paul Ryan et les républicains au congrès
laissent tomber,
ça va prendre un peu de temps.
GC : Mais aussi parce qu'ils sont tous préoccupé par la réélection,
et Trump a tellement de pouvoir pour que les gens soit pour vous
ou contre vous,
ils hésitent tous les jours, probablement :
« Dois-je aller contre ou pas ? »
Mais hier soir, où il a finalement eu un ton présidentiel,
la plupart des républicains poussent un soupir de soulagement aujourd'hui.
DB : La demi-vie de ce soupir est courte.
GC : D'accord - j'allais dire, jusqu'à ce que Twitter revienne.
CA : OK, je veux donner à chacun de vous la chance
d'imaginer que vous parlez - je ne sais pas -
aux gens sur internet qui regardent ce débat
qu'ils soient partisans de Trump,
qui puissent être de gauche, quelque part au centre.
Comment les conseilleriez-vous pour se rapprocher des autres
ou vous mettre à leur place ?
Pouvez-vous partager toute une sagesse finale à ce sujet ?
Ou si vous pensez qu'ils ne le devraient pas,
dites-le leur aussi.
GC : Je voudrais commencer par dire
que je pense vraiment tout changement et rapprochemente commence par le haut,
comme toute autre organisation.
Et j'aimerais, en quelque sorte,
si les partisans de Trump ou les gens de gauche
pourraient encourager leurs dirigeants
à montrer que la compassion venant d'en haut,
car imaginez le changement que nous pourrions avoir
si Donald Trump tweetait aujourd'hui,
à tous ses partisans,
« Ne soyons plus ignobles les uns envers les autres.
Soyons plus compréhensifs.
En tant que leader, je vais être plus inclusif
avec tous les peuples d'Amérique. »
Pour moi, ça commence au sommet.
Est-ce qu'il va le faire ? Je n'en ai aucune idée.
Mais je pense que tout commence par le haut,
et le pouvoir qu'il a
en encourageant ses partisans
à comprendre d'où les gens viennent de l'autre côté.
CA : David. DB : Oui, je suppose que je dirais
que je ne pense pas qu'on peut s'enseigner mutuellement à être civil,
et donner des sermons sur la civilité, ça ne le fera pas.
C'est comment nous agissons,
et le bon côté de Donald Trump est qu'il a fait exploser nos catégories.
Toutes les catégories auxquelles nous pensions sont obsolètes.
Elles ont été formidables pour le 20e siècle, pas aujourd'hui.
Il a un programme de fermeture des frontières et du commerce.
Je ne pense pas que ça va fonctionner.
Si on veut reconstruire les communautés, recréer des emplois,
on a besoin d'un programme différent
qui éclate toutes nos divisions et nos catégories actuelles.
À mon avis, ce programme est le Reaganisme pour la politique macroéconomique,
la Suède pour la politique sociale
et des coupes à droite et à gauche.
Nous devons avoir une économie qui crée une croissance.
C'est la politique économique de Reagan.
Mais les gens doivent avoir la base sécurisée.
Il faut des partenariats infirmier-famille ;
il faut une école maternelle pour tous ;
il faut des écoles privées sous contrat ;
il faut des programmes universitaires complémentaires
pour les parents et les communautés.
Nous devons aider à guérir la crise de solidarité sociale dans ce pays
aider à soigner les familles,
le gouvernement doit s'impliquer beaucoup plus
dans la manière dont les libéraux aiment reconstruire les communautés.
D'autre part, nous devons avoir une économie gratuite et ouverte
comme les conservateurs l'aimait avant.
Et donc c'est en ayant la bonne solution qu'on pulvérise
les identités partisanes,
parce que la base est en fin de compte ce qui façonne notre polarisation.
CA : David et Gretchen, merci beaucoup
pour un conversation fascinante.
Je vous remercie. C'était vraiment, vraiment intéressant.
(Applaudissements)
Continuons la conversation.
Nous continuons à essayer de comprendre
Si on peut ajouter quelque chose
pour continuer la conversation sur Facebook.
Donnez-nous votre avis
où que vous vous situez en politique,
Ce n'est pas que l'Amérique, c'est aussi le monde.
Nous n'allons pas finir aujourd'hui sans musique,
parce que si on mettait de la musique dans toute conversation politique,
le monde serait complètement différent, franchement.
Il le serait.
(Applaudissements)
À Harlem, cette femme extraordinaire ,
Vy Higginsen, qui est en fait ici -
regardons-la.
(Applaudissements)
Elle a créé ce programme qui rassemble des adolescents,
leur enseigne la joie et l'impact de la musique gospel,
et des centaines d'adolescents sont passés par ce programme.
C'est transformateur pour eux.
La musique qu'ils ont faite,
est extraordinaire
je ne vois pas de meilleure façon de terminer de ce dialogue TED
d'accueillir le Chœur Gospel de Harlem de Vy Higginsen.
Merci
(Applaudissements)
(Chant) Chœur: O beau pour les cieux spacieux
Pour les ondes de grain ambre
Pour les majestés des montagnes violettes
Au-dessus de la plaine fruitière
Amérique!
Dieu a versé sa grâce sur vous
Et couronne votre bien avec la fraternité
De la mer à la mer brillante
(Applaudissements)